well let us please welcome to the film
courage studio mr brian
j terwilliger his credits include one
six right one six left flying
full circle and the upcoming uh let's
see well
we'll talk about more as upcoming uh
projects to see brian's work
sorry i haven't had my coffee yet today
you can visit terwilligerproductions.com
welcome brian welcome brian well thank
you for having me guys thanks for being
here
let's start off first which came first
your love for film or your love
for flying it was flying ever since i
was a little kid
airplanes and i don't know how it
started but i was probably about five
years old and uh
model planes and air shows and movie
posters calendars everything in my room
had to do with airplanes it's actually
to this day my house now has
aviation art and a plane hanging from
the ceiling and like
it's a little obnoxious but i've always
loved planes
and it's been in my blood so a film
actually didn't even get on my radar
until i moved out to california
when i was 16 i had no exposure to the
industry
what brought you out to california uh
well an airplane
if i can tie that in but no i
grew up in connecticut my dad got a new
job out here in
la middle high school for me so
we came out and um that's it you kind of
showcased their influence um in a film
that you did call flying full circle a
10-minute
film i believe where you lived out your
dream to fly as a blue angel
what was that like wow um definitely
top 10 lifetime experience on so many
levels but
yeah growing up the air shows was a big
part of my childhood
and how many i went to in the blue
angels if you're not familiar just
the navy's flight demonstration team
they have six f-18s and
it's just incredible if you like
airplanes you like air shows they're
pretty much the
class act and i saw him many times and
you know i don't know what kid would not
want to fly with the blue angels
it's just an amazing sight and it's just
a very exciting inspiring
experience to see them so i got their
autographs when i was a kid
i don't remember how old i was right now
but got their autographs i met them it
was like meeting
you know your heroes it's like a bigger
than a celebrity you know when you're a
kid and you're watching they come out of
the jets and
somehow you think the jets are flying
themselves it's hard to remember there's
a human being or there's a pilot in
there
it's so amazing and so mechanical and so
perfect in terms of their formations
they come out these guys come out
and they come to the line and there's
all these kids and i got their
autographs and then
that really i think was a big part of
the inspiration of
deepening my love for flying and
aviation and my desire to become a pilot
myself which i did as a teenager
and then yeah the film industry kind of
came into my life when i was 16
17 in high school and eventually of
course
ended up making this film that we're
going to talk about but the opportunity
to fly with them
really was only because of one six right
the um so did you approach them or did
they approach you
i actually met a couple of the guys um
two years ago at an event and they were
familiar with the film
and said no kidding wow you know we love
that movie and
um it just one thing led to another and
they said you know you would be
you're the kind of guy we want to take
up you know we take certain amount of
vips every year and wow
and they're much more typically a
celebrity or an actor
or a politician or someone a race car
driver and that's who they take
not an independent filmmaker but because
it was an aviation film and what it
communicated
about the passion and about the industry
and kind of
said something that they really stood
behind and were appreciative of and said
you know you
deserve a ride we want to take you up
and what about the idea of documenting
it was that your idea or their idea
well part of getting the offer for a
ride
you have to provide some publicity for
them that's really
it's a two-way street anybody they take
obviously
what's in it for the rider is this
lifetime experience breaking the sound
barrier and you know
literally flying by the seat of your
pants just like top gun i mean it's
unbelievable
flying 100 feet off the deck at 500
miles an hour going through canyons i
mean literally is what we did
um but they need to get something out of
it too and that's
getting some sort of exposure some sort
of um
you know pr out of it so usually a
celebrity or a politician or a race car
driver
um just by their nature by their stature
gets
publicity you know a celebrity can go on
the jay leno show or something and
they'll do a roll in of a clip and you
know becomes a discussion point and
they're getting
big coverage well for me i don't have
that i didn't have that sort of
um leverage so i said well you know when
i bring a camera crew down and i'd love
to make a little film about it
and that's really the genesis of uh of
flying full circumstances so and seeing
you in the in the cockpit
yeah and you were doing rolls and and
what kind of
what were you doing up in the air yeah
we did you know a little bit of
everything pretty much what they do in
the show so
rolls loops very
steep turns and high g maneuvers even on
takeoff actually which is one of their
classic maneuvers
one of the solo pilots you take off but
you're about 10 feet over the ground and
you go down the entire length of the
runway and when you get to the very end
you just pull straight
up and it's about seven g's which is
seven times your body weight i mean you
basically feel like you're gonna
melt into your seat and then you go
straight up and i mean it's just
incredible but we broke the sound
barrier which is not something everyone
gets to do you have to be in
special areas and have permission to
break the sound barrier
um but we were able to do it um down
near san diego i fell centro
and uh that was a thrill to fly that
fast and it was amazing
and what was the fastest what was the
fastest speed like how fast were you
going
yeah the sound barrier um is around 750
miles an hour
wow about and it varies based on
temperature and altitude but
it's when you're doing it you don't hear
anything and you don't really
there's no sensation so in a sense it's
kind of a non-event
and any pilot will tell you that but um
from the ground it can break windows and
pop your eardrums and such if it was to
fly over you at low level
that's why you have to be very far away
and you have to get permission to do it
but from inside you're just watching
meters and things
show you're going through the sound
barrier breaking muck one and you know
the plane's starting to shake a little
bit and the ground is rushing by i mean
it's certainly intense
and you have to learn to breathe a
certain way or i mean do you black out
well you certainly can and that was
something i was very um
conscious of and was dedicated or not
dedicated but i was uh
just uh intent on not blacking out and
overcoming the forces but if you're not
a trained pilot and not trained for
those g's chances are you're going to
but yeah there's a way to breathe
there's a way to squeeze your legs to
keep the blood flow in your torso and
specifically in your head
because that's what makes you black out
and when you pull g's all the blood is
racing to your feet
because the the g-forces um are
literally bringing
the blood down so it becomes a problem
comes out of your head and if you're not
breathing correctly
or not squeezing in the right way even
for a second
then you're done so yeah i did end up
blacking out one time and i was
very disappointed in myself but oh well
now
let's talk filmmaking as well brandon do
you have what kind of filmmaking
background do you have
uh well in high school as i mentioned um
i had exposure to a film class it was a
film production class
and that's kind of where i got the bug
so we were doing editing and camera work
and that sort of thing and
my very first short film ever in that
class was actually building a model
airplane of mine oh it was the latest
model
radio controlled plane i was building so
i photographed or
videographed whatever the word is i
don't know what i don't know what i was
doing it was like an
vhs camera okay videotaping how about
that yeah um
the whole process was like a 250 hour
process to build this plane so it was
called workbench to runway and then of
course you end up seeing it fly in the
end and it was condensed about four
minutes long that was my first
film that's my first project you know
and as we continue
i just want to ask quickly i mean do you
have a marketing or business background
as well
as we lead into the as we're getting
closer yeah in college you know i
got a business degree actually i
realized going from those production
classes in high school into college that
i had some momentum doing freelance work
so i was doing grip electric
you know editing camera work um a little
bit of everything i was a projectionist
for three months to learn that part of
the business
wanted to be a producer i wanted to
literally learn everything i possibly
could so
the best way for me was doing a business
degree because i want to produce
and i got a business degree in college
and then during those four years i had
racked up over 100 credits of you know
one day and two day
little gigs okay um but i did just about
everything that i possibly could in
terms of
all of the technical parts of the craft
and then eventually became
and did some production managing and
first aiding and stuff like that and
you know i felt i had enough with that
with the business degree at some point
in my early 20s i said all right i'm
going to go make my own movie
awesome and so what compelled you to
eventually make
one six right well it's based on the van
nuys airport that's the home airport or
the main character if you will of the
film
and that's where i learned to fly okay
so i have a personal relationship with
that airport
uh i had the resources and the access to
people and planes and
um the more i learned about that
particular airport
it's just a fascinating place it's like
an air show every day they have the most
amazing they have jets they have
privately owned jets actually
there's not fighter jets but excuse me
not just business jets but they have a
couple
um old fighter jets that can break the
sound barrier believe it or not
but they have the small you know pits
biplanes and the piper cubs and the dc3s
they have it all
it's a very affluent area that we live
in and van nuys airport pretty much has
the best of the best
airplanes and then the history
casablanca was filmed there
the airport scenes marilyn monroe was
actually discovered there
that's literally how she got discovered
she's working on an assembly line and a
photographer saw her and it was
beginning of her career
it's just an amazing place that has so
many ties historically
as well as modern day and it just was
the great subject for a film so
one day i decided that was the topic of
my first movie
and and with your film you have the
tagline the romance of flying
which i think is is brilliant um
when and how did you come up with this
tagline for the film
you know i can't recall that actually um
i know the name of the movie wasn't
determined until very near the end of
filming
okay um just 1 6 right in general
although that name was on a list
early on we kind of had like this
brainstorming list of possible names for
the film and
it was one of the early ones and it was
pretty much discounted
early on no that's not it that's not
right and kept going and down these
lists and then eventually
came back i'm like no that's definitely
the title that's perfect that's what it
is
as far as the romance of flying um i
don't know i guess i kind of felt like
1608 was such an abstract name yeah
especially if you didn't know anything
about aviation
but that's kind of what i liked about it
i didn't want it to be and do we touch
on
what is one six right for those for
those listening exactly it's so abstract
you don't even know um which is
certainly worth noting one six right is
the name or the numbers on the main
runway
at van nuys airport okay so if you've
ever seen the beginning of a runway
there's usually some numbers
or an l or an r and what 1 6 right it
looks like the number 16
and then the letter r that's what it
looks like but the way a pilot says it
and the way you
you talk about the runway you say one
six right and what it is it's the
heading of the runway
so if you're sitting on the runway and
looking at your compass you're heading
160 degrees
you take off the zero so 180 or 180
degrees is due south
90 degrees is east 270s west
360 or zero is north so one six is
basically
southeast and uh there's right and left
because there's parallel runways you
need to know the difference so if you're
clear to land one six right
you know exactly which runway and it's
hopefully they're right
how much money did you have to raise to
make this film
uh gosh um
a lot but not nearly enough how's that
okay um
it took uh it
it kept going up the budget probably
very typical
sure um originally i ca in fact i found
it wasn't too long ago i was going
through some paperwork and i found the
original budget that i wrote for the
film
okay and it became i don't know probably
about uh
five times more expensive than that from
the original budget when i first started
had this idea
okay um but when i started raising money
i knew that was not the right number i
was reading about three times that and
then it just
two more times i had to continue to
raise more money for the film which is
you know
not unheard of certainly and i guess
there's two options when you get to that
point either you run out of money and
you say well this
is what i've got you know this is i've
used all the resources and
movie is what it is or in my case i just
kept going and
i was unsatisfied until i had made
completely the film i wanted to make and
put more and more and more on the line
to do that going back to investors and
leveraging things in my personal life to
to see it through but um
right and and so were you filming
like when you raised the money were you
in production and then you would have to
go back so
it was that was that the process once i
raised the the
amount of money that i thought it was
going to take not that original
budget on paper but when i actually had
a dollar amount and i raised it like all
right cool we're home free here we go
okay we're done
um we're good to go this is the easy
part let's go make the movie which of
course is not the case
there's nothing easy about it um but we
started shooting we started going out
doing interviews and b-roll
and we shot i don't know six or seven
times over 14 months so we'd go out for
anywhere between three to ten days
at a time maybe every six weeks or so
over 14 months
and and how and how long did it take to
raise the money and how did you
where were you turning where was this
money coming from the money
i was going to people at the airport
primarily because i felt they would have
they'd get it they'd have the interest
in it they'd want to support it they'd
love to see this movie memorial or the
airport memorialized in the way that i
intended
and um i thought there the people had
the money they had the means certainly
the people i was approaching
but it was not easy at all because
they're like okay you want this much
money
you want to make a movie about van nuys
airport but really who is going to ever
see this film who is really genuinely
going to be interested in a movie about
the van nuys airport and i'm sure anyone
listening to this is probably
questioning the same thing well yeah
you have to go to
terwilligerproductions.com and you have
to you have to see
this footage you know and well thank you
very much and i
think that um the secret to any movie
and you can make it about
any topic and as long as you can take
the
audience invested in whatever it is that
you're trying to convey
i believe uh it could be as abstract as
a piece of paper in the san fernando
valley and make it interesting
if you have interesting people and an
interesting angle and something that
people begin to care about
in the case of 1 6 right the visuals and
the music and some of the stories
bring it to life so eventually the way
that i convinced these people to write
checks
was not had nothing to do with what i
was doing on paper
because it didn't make sense and it was
flat on paper
uh and in budgets and and a website that
i was trying to explain
again in writing what this was but i
went out and i shot
uh basically a trailer it was a teaser i
was calling it
incorrectly calling it a trailer at the
time of course that's after the film's
done but
i went out shot footage borrowed camera
got a crew and cut together a five
minute piece
and it was a sample if you will of this
is what the movie's gonna be like and i
had the big music and
some interviews with a few key people
that were willing very early on to do it
and within six weeks of showing that
clip is when i had raised all the money
and that was about two years before that
i didn't explain but all of the time i
was kind of trying to court these
investors and
creating new documents and truly trying
to rally the troops
finally when i made a sample of my
product the prototype
this is some of the best advice that i
can relay
but they're not investors and the people
that you want to support your film
aren't filmmakers
probably and they're also not
visionaries they can't see a piece of
paper
and understand exactly what you're doing
and it isn't an indication of
your vision either or your talent or
what the experience of a motion picture
is when story music and visuals come
together so you show that sample
and they're gonna get it so just to
clarify you spent over two years
attempting to raise the money
and then you said you know what i'm just
going to show them what i want to do
after two years and then from there six
weeks and you got
your full budget literally six weeks yep
and i made uh
a thousand of these dvds so i actually
authored a dvd with the menus and you
know we
went over the top with this thing and
then we actually replicated a thousand
not burned them under
literally like replicating like you do
okay and your final death with the
shrink wrap
the whole deal yeah well didn't have
shrink wrap but they were actually you
know pressed
at a real production house um and uh
yeah they were they had special
packaging it wasn't a regular mra case
we had a special other custom way to
present this disc
but i gave away to anybody and everybody
that would want to see this
and we had piles of them around the
airport i was mailing them around the
country and just getting some interest
and support and of course got them to
everyone i was
speaking with all along and it just came
together and then how many investors did
it take
to get to you know how many did you it
was twelve twelve investment
investors came on board yep wow and and
how did you
go about filming these planes in the air
i mean there's some just beautiful shots
how did you do that the aerials are all
done with a helicopter
so we have a gyroscopic mounted on the
nose of a helicopter an a-star
um for any techies out there it's a
f-950
sony camera that's in a gyron gyroscopic
ball
and so we brief on the ground with the
pilots what we're going to do where
we're going to go
what kind of maneuvers we anticipate
doing and then we go up there
and it's definitely one of the most fun
parts of filming
and you're you're in the helicopter yep
i'm in the helicopter in the back seat
and i have a
hd monitor and then the camera operator
is in the front
left seat and the pilot of a helicopter
is always in the front right seat
and we're all talking on you know our
own headsets and radios and then we can
talk to the pilot and
it's a really coordinated ballet between
all of the people and the shots that
we're trying to get and
it's uh we're very close to these planes
at times and in a rotor blade of a
helicopter and an airplane is a very odd
combination to be in formation
so it's a very but the helicopter
pilot's amazing his name is kevin larosa
and he's done
over 100 movies including pearl harbor
and iron man and
you name it so he is just a total pro
and he of course he's based out of van
nuys airport where most of the movie
helicopter pilots are
and how long are you up in the air you
know documenting this
the limiting factor is the fuel in the
helicopter because we're doing hd
we have unlimited tape loads so um the
helicopter the flight time is about an
hour
and a half maybe an hour 40 minutes and
are you satisfied every time you go up
yeah you can't mess up pretty much
getting footage in a helicopter it is
just the view from above
and the kind of planes we were filming
and the days that we were fortunate to
get
and the times of days that's a critical
part too you want to shoot always in
golden hour
uh and especially for an aerial so yeah
so we were incredibly pleased in fact we
rolled something about shooting hd in
the air versus film
for the last several decades and still
actually a lot of big motion pictures
are shooting film
and space cams and west cams but they
have like 11 minute loads on a thousand
foot
mag so you're needing to actually re you
need to land the helicopter to reload
the camera and when you're shooting in
golden hour you only have like you know
maybe 45 minutes of the light that you
really want so you have to
manage earn you know 11 minutes
over that amount of time and you might
you know popping the camera on and off
you can might miss the shot that you
really wanted or there was an accident
and you weren't rolling
that sort of thing hd we roll before we
physically take off when everything's
booted up and the camera system is
booted up and the helicopter is warming
up we start recording
and we'll switch tapes in the middle of
the flight which is about a 60 second
reload
and we don't turn the thing off until we
land so we get every single second
and that's a huge advantage over film in
the air
and then during the course of time that
you're trying to raise money and you
have this vision for this film
what are you doing to support yourself
and what's your mindset that's keeping
you going
wow um that's a great question and
my answer the reality was when i
was determined to make the film
and i had raised the money to do it that
was it
i stopped any other activity in my life
i mean
professionally and pretty much socially
i literally became
um completely dedicated to this effort
no matter what it takes
and that is just the way that i think if
i really want something
i need i'm going all in this is it i
didn't have a day job
you know what people would ask me that
actually along the way how are you
paying the bills what's your you know
day-to-day how do you
no you know this is it this is what i am
doing and i didn't know any other way
any better way
to have my head all the way in this
thing um
and you know it's not easy it's probably
not recommended
um if you're interested in you know
positive cash flow and
and that sort of thing but um to me and
i think most filmmakers have this
mentality of being willing to do what it
takes and they know that
how difficult and what the challenge is
and the odds are against you getting it
made
and for me it was having no distractions
whatsoever
and living eating breathing sleeping
having nightmares whatever it might be
about this film and seeing it all the
way through to the end
you are listening to film courage we
broadcast live every sunday we're here
in studio on a thursday
at 11 a.m pacific standard time here at
la talk radio dot com
we are speaking with filmmaker brian j
tur williger
and to see his work visit tur will tur
williger i i don't know why i have
trouble with your last name brian
terwilligerproductions.com extraordinary
stuff there
now brian i want to segue here because
we're going to start talking
distribution
are you familiar with the chinese bamboo
tree i'm not
all right here we go there we go
zig ziglar the famous motivational
speaker tells us the story
of the chinese bamboo tree and i you
know i believe this this relates to what
we're getting ready to discuss here
when planted watered and nurtured for an
entire growing season
doesn't outwardly grow as much as an
inch
then after the second growing season a
season in which the farmers
the farmer takes extra care to water
fertilize and care for the bamboo tree
this the tree still hasn't sprouted so
it goes as the sun rises
and sets for four solid years the farmer
and his wife have nothing
tangible to show for all of their labor
trying to grow the tree
then comes along year five in the fifth
year the chinese bamboo tree
seed finally sprouts and the bamboo tree
grows up to eighty feet in just one
growing season
did the little tree lie dormant for four
years only to grow exponentially in the
fifth
or was the little tree growing
underground developing a root system
strong enough to support its potential
for outward growth
in the fifth year and beyond the answer
of course is obvious
had the tree not developed a strong
unseen foundation that could not have
sustained its life
as it grew had the chinese bamboo farmer
dug up the little seed every year to see
if it was growing
he would have stunted the tree's growth
as surely as a caterpillar is doomed
to a life on the ground if it is freed
from its struggle inside a cocoon
prematurely
the struggle in the cocoon is what gives
the future butterfly the
wing power to fly
you know so it's amazing that's
wonderful
you know you sold 10 000 units of one
six right in its first two weeks on dvd
um you did this independently obviously
you did not do this by luck
um so you know let's start with um at
what point did you decide you were going
to self-distribute the film
oh my gosh so many you've just evoked so
many wonderful
thoughts um hard to focus on the
questions
let's hear something that was such a
wonderful um uh
it wasn't a poem it was a from a famous
motivational speaker
yeah i think he wrote that yeah he's a
great speaker i mean i i couldn't relate
more um so i need to comment on that in
relation to the making of the film
before we even
segue to distribution if i can it's all
related actually it's the same
the same sentiment and the same
perseverance that is needed i believe
and certainly was my
the secret of my success it certainly
wasn't my background or my talent or my
connections or family in the business
which was not the case i didn't go to
film school
none of these things i just was so
dedicated to the craft and to my end
goal
and i knew when i didn't have it um that
like you know you're speaking of this
fourth going into the fifth year and it
actually was my timeline was five years
by the way
two years before i started raising the
money and then um
and it was in the fifth year that the
film had its premiere believe it or not
so actually that timeline i kind of
relate to
you know when i thought of your story
this is this is what i thought it it
really is um it's right on so
uh but in the making of the film i knew
and say let's say you're four
and it really was year four i knew that
it didn't have
the film yet and it wasn't quite what it
could be
it wasn't quite what i wanted it to be
but it was a movie it worked
it played um you know we had a cut in
fact i had a final cut it was october
and i had a final cut and i actually sat
down and spotted
um the film with my composer and my
mixer
and we started outputting the time code
and picture which is
the process of going through the next
stages of post you know the final stages
and then that was october and then
sometime in
november or december i decided nope this
isn't it i'm just it's still not
right i'm settling um i don't have it so
i and continue to raise more money
i was i had to do whatever had to do
because all that matters in the end to
the point of the
story the bamboo tree all that matters
in the end is what that final product is
and you might be a day away
from it's sprouting and you give up or
you settle
or you throw in the towel or whatever it
is and
the future of the bamboo tree or the
film it's really dependent on that final
final product when you push the button
you say that's it
um i'm now i'm no longer watering it
because it is
everything i wanted it to be right so
that didn't happen until like may of
2005 so it was another six months or so
and that made all the difference that
last six months was the equivalent of
you know the last year in the story and
if it wasn't for what i did in those six
months without question
we would not be sitting here today the
movie would have done nothing i mean
i don't say that lately i did not have a
great film and even now i mean people
like it or not like it but
it's had it's done well enough that it's
done what i wanted it to do and i made
the film that i wanted to make and at
the end of the day
i could walk away and no matter how well
or how poorly the movie was received i
had made
the best movie that i could and i knew
that and the feeling that satisfaction
when i completely maxed out
everything that i had to give this thing
there's that's it there's no better
feeling you know i have accomplished no
matter what it took i arrived
i didn't compromise and uh that
perseverance
and knowing when your gut says i don't i
still don't quite have it
you know and you have every reason to
give up and it's hard and it's in year
four and you know it's still an inch
tall
um you know if you really believe in it
and it's not just they have four years
invested in it it's that you really
believe in it
so you just keep going you don't know
it's going to be your five it could be
your seven
so do you want it or not you know and
are you willing to do whatever it's
going to take and again i don't
necessarily recommend this
uh for everybody it's not sane advice
but it's
i believe that what it really it takes
to see it through and distribution was
no different
when i finished the film i realized now
retrospectively
i was 50 done with my journey
distribution was the second half
and at what point do you decide okay i'm
gonna do this on my own
um so thank you for bringing me back to
that um
basically i never intended to distribute
this on my own that wasn't the point
i thought i could get a distributor like
probably every filmmaker wants
i had invited several to my premiere uh
we did a you know a big
fanfare in hollywood and the whole thing
and of course
it was you know we had 800 or 900 people
come out it was
that's the night of my life but
not one distributor you know no one that
wasn't directly related somehow to the
film or
family or something so um it just
people weren't interested it was really
hard to rally anybody to come out we
didn't do film festivals at all so
that's certainly another
disadvantage of actually trying to get
people to see this and get distribution
but it isn't the kind of film
it doesn't have that edge and that
expose maybe that's more common the grit
the topical
uh you know nature of documentaries and
there's not even a handheld shot in this
film
it's a very different kind of film and
maybe it's too nice or sweet of a film
you know to really get that
that edge and that punch that maybe is
more common and more desirable and more
commercial
in documentaries so with some further
effort post premiere
i was realizing in about i don't know 60
to 90 days
uh in the summer of 2005 that this was
never
never going to get the kind of
distribution that could offset
the work and the cost that it took to
make the film so again i had two options
either
i accept some offer and i get a
distribution deal and i just know that
we'll never make this money back i'll
never live up to the promises i made to
my investors
or the intent the very very serious
intent that i made to my investors to
get their money back
or i find another way
and now i put the same passion and the
same energy and the same effort and the
same perseverance
behind getting this film seen and
getting it distributed because i believe
it
that much and that's the course that i
took
so and what you know because it's a hard
decision to make
um what what made you believe you could
be successful on your own distributing
this film
i believed i could do it because i
understood or
let me phrase this i never expected or
had any particular path or intent of
which we've now taken
but i just knew that i could do better
than any offer given to me
that's what i knew i knew that
with the people not the people with the
audience
that we had already people were
following the film we had
again this is 2004 going into 2005. so
we didn't have
twitter and facebook and a lot of the
tools
more tools that are available now for
that groundswell of viral marketing but
we did have a website and we did have
people opting in with emails and kept
them in the loop and
that sort of thing so i knew that i had
an audience base that was ready and
willing to embrace the film and see the
film
so i already knew i had that that was in
my back pocket
so basically i pursued that path and put
it on our website and decided that
self-distributing the see the dvds
directly to that audience would be the
way to start
and so one day the eve of thanksgiving
2005 when the dvd went for release
is when we pushed the button and sent
the email to
everybody on the list i think there are
about 12 000 people
on that list and the rest is history
and did you pay for ads anywhere no no
in fact to this day
email i don't believe we've ever paid
for any advertising and i believe that
to be a factual statement we
just recently we got a full page ad and
a pretty major aviation magazine
up actually for two or three months in a
row that was offered and donated and
we've done different things and ways to
swap services and
things with exposure that we have gotten
and apple and some other
entities we've made some arrangements
with there's been win wins
however we've never paid for advertising
that hasn't been a path that
has made sense for us we didn't have
that kind of money or p a budget to
really be
paying for that we really went off the
ground swell and word of mouth
so who handled all of the orders it was
like through a website and
who handled all it was through our own
website at first and that only lasted
for those
infamous two weeks or two and a half
weeks um in the beginning
and it was the one thing for sure i
would never do
again and it was selling them directly
we weren't licking stamps by any means
we did have a fulfillment house
so we had a real-time credit card
transaction on our website
you place the order and then the order
uh goes to
this fulfillment house and they
basically
you know whatever they do they they
print out the the label and put it in
the box and charge us
x amount of dollars for it and put it in
the mail or fedex or whatever the chosen
method of of shipping is but what the
problem was with this even though the
money comes directly to us
so that real time credit card processing
goes to our bank account it's happening
real time
the customer service angle is what i
never
anticipated so in other words there's no
middleman there's no person
selling this in between me and the
customer even though
there's a fulfillment house doing the
actual labor
of the shipping there is no one in
between to deal with the problems and
you'd never expect there's going to be
problems
but there were tons of problems so the
package didn't arrive on time it didn't
arrive in good condition
they ordered two dvds there was only one
before the holidays actually leading
right into the holidays certain people
hadn't arrived on time they were doing
mail so they wanted the cheapest first
class mail for the dvd
and things were running behind it was
actually an infamous year for the mail
they had all kinds of issues that
particular year i think they've gotten
better but
um the internet and the types of of uh
volume that particular year for the us
post office i remember because we were
caught in the middle of it
had a real serious problem so it was
taking 10 days to get somewhere well
meanwhile
they left and they were now going to the
grandma's house or something so they
call us or email us and want us to
somehow pluck it out of the air
and reroute it to a different location
well the amount of problems in emails
we had is unspeakable it was it was
most difficult time actually i think
one of the most difficult times in the
entire making of the film because
it was like a monster we created it was
they were selling at an incredible rate
but the liability and the potential
problem of every single sale
was now kind of coming back and it was
it was compounding the problems were
compounding and there weren't things we
were doing
but there were things that were just
part of being
in the business of selling something a
product so amazon.com
for example is an expert at this this is
what they do
they they have customer service they
ship there's something wrong you deal
with them
um they're gonna ship it out again
they'll deal with whatever costs are
involved to keep the customer happy
that's what they do
so my advice for sure would be go direct
to amazon or something like it
right away and don't try to cut out that
middleman yes amazon takes a huge
percentage
relative to what we could retain but the
volume they do
and the way they do it and the ease that
it makes
on you you can focus on other parts and
just like i said volume alone
makes up for it because there's many
people that come to our website
so many more hear about it and see it on
amazon and they have referrals and if
people bought this they recommend that
and it really works and so
it didn't take it took me a year
actually before we went to amazon
and that was a mistake i should have
gone to them right away and um
we would have sold i think a lot more in
year one if we had
and really what i want to touch on here
is is
it sounds like you know the sales were
directly from your website
um that you had an email list of 12 000
people
but how are people getting to your
website and you know and
you know i mean how are they getting
there in the first place and how are you
getting this there's 12 000 people to
sign up well the website was live for
the 18 months prior to its release
so it was just kind of this growing um
swell if you will of interest and
aviation is a pretty tight community to
begin with
but we also so we did a lot of things
though to get people there part of it's
word of mouth and people are saying have
you heard about this have you seen this
actually not forget now we had a clip
that's right if you put your email
address in you get to see a clip and the
only way to see this clip
was to basically you know pass go which
was putting an email
address and certainly some people aren't
working we're going to put an email
address in anyways but
you know it worked for us we had other
clips that were available but that was
an additional thing you got to see and
it was a really really cool clip we were
really really proud of
and people would talk about that and the
only way to do it was to put their email
in and so they had some interest
to see the website and see the product
so that's that was a big part of it and
we also made movie posters we made like
half size one sheets and we made a
couple thousand of them and we mailed
them all over the country to put them up
at airports
it was it's literally the final movie
poster but it said coming soon
and had the website on it so people you
know got intrigued they saw the key art
and they kind of
had an image branded for 18 months
before it came out and so
those are some of the things we did
tricks what percentage of the sales were
individual
versus bulk um when you say bulk
house i mean did you have any large
you know people ordering 100 copies at
once a thousand like i mean ten thousand
is a substantial amount of copies to
sell i think um
i think the average order was about two
actually which is huge actually
average meaning many people were
ordering three and four
tons of them were at one but i think it
was about fifty percent were
one and the other fifty percent of the
orders were more than one
and at some points i think they were 20
and 25 at a time
i know people personally that i've met
along the way that said yeah i bought 20
or 30
for christmas for my friends and family
that year so
excuse me there oh how long did it take
to make your money back
it took i don't know exactly
the the amount of time we were
reinvesting a lot of what was coming in
back into efforts to to keep it going to
fan the flames if you will
so i don't remember the exact moment
that we broke even it was probably
sooner than it could have been if we
invested nothing but to keep that
momentum you really do have to keep you
know watering the tree if you will
um but it happened you know relatively
quickly um so
you know one thing though we didn't
anticipate by the way is making those
dvds actually
you finish the film just decide to
self-distribute
you author the dvd and you actually make
the physical
product you know and you and they're on
pallets and they're shipping on trucks
and you kind of forget about this
with itunes and new media you don't have
to worry about this but the liability
and the expense of actually having a
product that
can take up you know half of a semi
tractor trailer which it did
is is just a huge amount of product and
the money it cost us to make that
product was over a hundred thousand
dollars
and that didn't was never anticipated in
the budget and certainly
prior to deciding to self-distribute
that was never a line item never a
consideration so we had to come up with
literally over six figures to make the
actual
product just to start ever making money
you can't make money if you don't have
something to sell
so if you go to the new media route only
then that what i just said is
irrelevant but um so that first hundred
thousand in was just repaying the
physical hard costs
of the actual products we had to create
and you know you've done a lot more with
one six right than simply a
theatrical run and sell it on dvd i mean
can you touch on some of the other
methods
in terms of how you've distributed this
film um
you know we've tried to basically
um find a place for this everywhere and
anywhere so it went to um
of course amazon and netflix you know
have it and then dvd but itunes we did a
deal with them it's available there
uh we now have it run on pbs it's still
running actually on pbs
nationwide and uh the different
different markets schedule their
programs differently so it's on
different times everywhere but it's
still airing through next year the
contract ends next year and discovery
channel
has aired it multiple times debuted on
christmas day 2006
but they have rights to play it as many
times as they want for three years and
in flight entertainment well we did a
deal with that we've done a lot of stock
footage
deals because the uh the imagery has
been really of interest to a lot of
different
people and commercials and things so
that's been another avenue of revenue
so the more revenue sources and the more
visibility and the more exposure
obviously the more distribution paths
all add up to the most volume which is
really obviously the goal
see you know sometimes what's so tough
about doing this show is you know like i
said these 50 minutes go so fast i i do
have one more question i want to touch
on and obviously there's so much more
that we love to pick your brain about
and you do have an open window to come
back and get further thank you
and talk and talk all this with us on
the next run um but if i want to mimic
the success that you've had with one six
right
what are some of the intangibles that
i'm gonna have to have and my film is
gonna have to have
or or is it even possible for me to do
what you've done
well we're just trying to repeat what
we've done
and uh you know i i don't know if there
it is i think a little bit
uh you know a lot of things went right
you know with this film um no pun
intended once it's right but
they did you know and um
i i guess i don't know if there's any
secret sauce and as
cheesy as it may sound but truly
perseverance i mean you have to have a
decent idea to begin with and you have
to have some
ability to pull it off i mean those are
givens you know but
it's really um seeing something through
and believing in it to in whatever
that's going to take to do and
it sounds so abstract but that is my
philosophy and that's what we're doing
right now with our new projects
and i feel like if you believe in what
you're doing
and you make the film that you want to
make not the film that other people want
to make
that it will become something pure
and something authentic and i believe
that really is what's required
of art and um you know in our case of
course we did have an audience
aviation that's a tight-knit community
it's inherently very passion-filled
and those are things going for us
certainly but um
you know it's hard to say you know it's
if filmmakers and some
people have made blockbuster films and
biggest films and the highest-grossing
films of all time
if studios had a formula to replicate
success
um you know it'd be a different world
that's very difficult every film is
different
and you know i don't think there's any
easy answer
you know i just have one one quick last
question what did you tell yourself
when you felt like giving up or maybe
you didn't maybe you just had the
singular focus
and there was nothing that was going to
deter you but
if anything was there any type of a
mantra something that just kept you
going or you just knew there was no
you had to keep that's good great
question um
and i guess i'm trying to think what it
might be i guess
you don't fail until you give up it's
kind of a philosophy of mine okay and it
really goes back to the story about the
bamboo tree
and if you really believe in it and you
believe it's gonna succeed and can
succeed and that
that bamboo tree's got everything going
for and you're doing all the right
things
and you have every reason to believe
it's possible
then it really is possible so i i guess
that was it
um and with the investment that i had
it's
i don't know failure and turning around
and stopping wasn't an option it was a
much much
darker um answer to stop than it was to
continue
and i guess that uh that's the
determining factor
uh brian um your story is so inspiring
to karen and i
um thank you and i imagine for all of
our listeners thank you for sharing your
story
and insights with us here today if you
haven't gone yet
you have to visit
terwilligerproductions.com
and forgive me that that added eye in
there it's
t-e-r-w-i-l-i-g-e-r
productions.com thank you so much thank
you for having me
thank you